what else you guys been up to huh well i
i see what you guys have been up to and
that's uh getting your first vaccine
shot that was
broadcasted live oh yeah we did on like
japanese television
that's all right i got [ __ ] stared
down by like the minister of health or
whatever he was
yeah yeah the aussie again i guess the
anthony fountain of japan
yes essentially yeah but um yeah we got
uh
is it weird to say that our vaccine was
sponsored because this video is
sponsored by
in a sense it kind of was but not really
well it wasn't it wasn't i mean you know
i don't know we didn't get paid to get
vaccines so
i guess it wasn't sponsored yeah so the
uh the company that
we work for it's obviously a subsidiary
of a subsidiary which is owned by
katakawa yeah
and karakawa in japan you know and you
know i disagree with this
they were only really giving the
vaccines out to big companies with over
a thousand employees i think
yeah to give so that they could give it
to their um
employees yeah but i just think that you
should just give it to anyone who wants
it yeah because apparently uh you know
people the all the population here
haven't been too receptive to it they
haven't been taking it much
uh whatever so yeah they had it and uh i
believe katakawa was uh was like all
right well let's make it a press event
yeah um and so yeah because duango which
is the company that owns nico nico which
is like
the japanese youtube essentially they
wanted to like do this program where
they were like
we need to get foreigners living in
japan vaccine
because you know we want to show that
off right being like it doesn't matter
if you're a foreigner you can get
vaccine to your guys yet like like every
foreigner living here isn't like can you
just give me the [ __ ] vaccine yeah
we know the vaccine says so yeah they
were like
well trash taste has a lot of foreigners
in it yeah
so they were like yeah you can have the
vaccine if you go on tv
and i was thinking like [ __ ] well it
could be months before i get it here
yeah
i'm gonna get it you know yeah it's you
know it's not it's not like i've never
done this before sure
[ __ ] it i'll get stabbed on tv yeah at
least again at least you weren't given
the death glare yeah right yeah well so
what's happening
is that we turn up to this place and we
fill out a form
and there's already like people like
shuffling us around and like obviously
it's a very strange experience if you've
never been on like a press thing um
and to be honest we haven't been on many
but essentially you turn up at a place
and then like a group of 10 people are
like
come here come here do this thing do
this thing and then they're shoving you
around and you're just like all right
okay i'll just keep following and then
you like to fill out this form fill it
out now
all right okay i forgot come here come
here you've got to get to do this and
then i'm like all right well all right
well [ __ ] what's going on
meanwhile this entire time it this
entire thing is live streamed
on nico nico in front of i think it was
like 35 000 people
yeah something yeah i don't know what 35
000 people are just watching i'm just
sitting there watching people getting
vaccinated
i'm not sure if it was total views or
live views but it was a lot
yeah and so i saw how many comments
there were and it just like completely
filled up the screen yeah
with niko nico it's not like youtube
comments where you can read them down on
like
on like the bottom like if you comment
something it like appears live on the
feed
it's pretty cool but also really
distracting yeah it's a cool it's a cool
feature i think yeah yeah so then we get
shuffled across to this other room with
like 20 cameras and a bunch of people
and me and jerry just looks so out of
place because everyone is wearing suits
and we're just like all right and and
connor and i are rocking in our jojo's
yeah we're wearing
shirts i was like if i'm going on tv i'm
wearing jojo and then they'll like sit
down here and i was like okay cool and
literally like two seconds later after
they told us to sit down
uh the health minister yeah comes around
the corner and like
like emperor palpatine just stares us
down like
yeah what the [ __ ] was up with that
death stare he gave you guys so so
before that as well right
he's like he's like how was it and we
were and i enjoyed it
no he looked at me and he was like in
english he was like how was it and i'm
like
i was this close to being like bro i
literally just walked in
like we haven't got here we're waiting
yeah so jerry didn't respond and we were
really awkward you're like confused and
yeah as he's walking i'm like oh we
haven't had it yet and he goes oh
and then just walks off but then has a
five minute conversation with the
japanese cosplayers and me and joe are
like all right well yeah
all right can we go we're now like there
were japanese cosplays there yeah there
was someone uh from final fantasy 7 next
to me
just in cosplay cosplay
[Laughter]
it was really strange was it was this
like a vaccine
like event or was this like [ __ ]
anime expo or something
i think i think i think the event was to
like they got they were japanese
influencers yeah they were japanese
so it was like foreign influences
japanese influences musicians talents
all that kind of stuff
they just came in costume yeah they came
in so weird
well i think what we don't really give a
[ __ ] i think the japanese talent very
much you should care about holding the
yeah like the e-mailing
[ __ ] we're just talking about joking
yeah i guess that's holding the image
right
yeah and then when i was getting the
vaccine uh
from my periphery like i could see from
my peripheries as the health middle
staring down on me like this is really
funny video of like four angles of
this guy just staring at joe with like a
whole press team behind him
it was really bizarre it looks so
[ __ ] ominous it was like a scene from
like [ __ ] jojo or something it looked
like a parody
like when especially when they're like i
was
[Music]
because when i went because i went like
a few hours afterwards because i was
busy winning a shadowverse tournament at
the time
by the way but uh yeah i came in
afterwards and it was like pretty chill
for me
i didn't have any cameras no interview
did you guys have to do interviews or
anything like that no
we just went on like a live stream
afterwards and said yeah watch trash
taste
yeah did you did you have to sit in
front of like there was like a weird
like shrine
looking thing after you got the shot
after
after we got the show one of the there
was like seven camera angles on this
nico [ __ ] live stream but one of the
camera angles was through
it was on this table and it was through
these like tory gates it was a really
[ __ ] angle
it was a really [ __ ] angle you could
barely see our faces but basically they
were like
once we got the shots done we came out
and they were like oh sit down and give
us a couple of like
words on how your experience was so
connor and i got sat in front of this
story
shrine and they were like how was it i
was like a [ __ ] needle wasn't it
i've done this before dude it's just
it's just the vaccine but then we
use that as the opportunity to be like
what's trash taste oh really
yeah damn promoting trash chasering a
vaccine yeah i guarantee
most of them didn't understand what we
said but it's all right it's the thought
that counts
i saw sydney's clip where she went in
front of it and she just says
yeah i'm an error gay youtuber and
she literally said that and the comments
were just like what everyone thought she
was like a jp actress
oh my god poor choice of words but uh
yeah i mean so yeah i guess i traded
uh you know i just let them we were
guinea pigs for the press so that we can
get vaccines
worse honestly yeah honestly like when
when we got the
when we got like the offer from mainland
like mainland just messages us one day
and was like
guys good news i can secure you guys a
vaccine and we're just like great
well as you know as you know as
hopefully many companies are getting
vaccinated right now that's [ __ ]
brilliant
uh and then she was like but there's a
catch i was like
would you what do you mean there's a
[ __ ] catch i'm just i just want to
get vaccinated
it's like well you can get it if you
appear on
nico nico and live stream it i'm just
like what kind of sponsorship offer is
this this is like literally the weirdest
sponsorship offer i've ever heard in my
life
i've never done anything it kind of felt
like it at the time but
it wasn't technically a sponsorship
offer but uh slowly getting there
yeah first jab complete next one and uh
the end of this month
yeah we'll be fully five g'd up yeah
yeah
i'm honestly impressed because it just
seemed like a switch just like flicked
in like the japanese vaccination program
like we went from no vaccines to
everyone's getting a vaccine now well
yeah because i think it's because the
government finally realized they were
like
olympics is a month away and no one's
been vaccinated yet yeah they were like
that's
we should probably do something about
that because japan normally isn't
isn't used to really having eyes on them
they're normally kind of very much like
that
yeah and now they have all the eyes on
them yeah they're watching literally
everything they do in criticizing it
not i don't think they're like used to
it yeah
but uh america is like first time huh
i got these like really [ __ ] awful
back pains
like the day after i got the vaccine
shot like you know most of the time it's
like oh my
you know my left arm or whatever army
god was saw you know i got on the left
arm and like yeah this entire part was
just
aching like [ __ ] crazy and i was like
yeah i'm feeling sleepy i'm feeling
drowsy
meanwhile i woke up the next day and i
was like i feel like someone just like
dropped kicked me in the back
i don't know why sounds strange i've
never heard anyone say that right it's
like
only me and aki are the only ones that
have got this side effect
everyone else was just like if i
screamed too loudly you might you might
[ __ ] turn into a type
joke it was like [ __ ] historian
looking at me right it's just like you
better know sometimes you're [ __ ]
tired and i swear to god
we're gonna put a spoiler the first ever
just casual spoiler